THAT'S WHAT'S DIFFERENT THIS
TIME.
>> Bret: GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
>> OKAY.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS ARE CALLING
ON SOME OF THEIR MOST
HIGH-PROFILE STAR ATTRACTIONS TO
TRY TO RAMP UP SUPPORTS AHEAD OF
TUESDAY'S VOTING.
FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA WE'VE SEEN
ON THE TRAIL, VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN TAKING PART.
SO IS OPRAH WINFREY.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
MIKE EMANUEL SHOWS US TONIGHT.
>> THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS, LIKE,
THE CROWD WE ALL GET TO WHERE.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE BRINGING OUT
MAJOR STAR POWER.
OPRAH WINFREY IN JOSIE
CHOSE >> All:
GEORGIA TRYING TO GET STACY
>> IN A LIGHT INTO
>> STEPPING OUT TO STEP ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WHERE SOME WOULD
LOVE TO SEE OPRAH FOR PRESIDENT
IN 2020, AN IDEA SHE'S RESISTING
FOR NOW.
>> I DON'T WANT TO RUN, OKAY?
I AM NOT TRYING TO TEST ANY
WATERS...
>> OTHER HOLLYWOOD STARS GOT THE
ATTENTION OF VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE.
>> I HEARD OPRAH IS IN TOWN
TONIGHT.
I'D
LIKE STACY, OPRAH, WILL FERRELL,
I'M KIND OF A BIG DEAL TOO.
>> FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
JOE BIDEN TODAY TRIED TO RESCUE
ENDANGERED INCUMBENT HEIDI
HEITKAMP AD TESTED OUTLINES HE
MAY USE IT HIS OWN PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
>> OUR SILENCE IS COMPLICITY,
BUT WE WILL NOT REMAIN SILENT.
>> ALSO A DEFENSE OF MISSOURI
SENATOR CLAIRE McCASKILL AND
ATTACKED REPUBLICANS FOR ATTACKS
IN PEOPLE WITH PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
>> EITHER NOT TELLING THE TRUTH
OR REALLY STUPID OR BOTH.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS BEEN OUT
ON THE TRAIL TRYING TO RALLY
DEMOCRATS AND THAT TIMES TAKING
VEILED SWIPES AT HIS SUCCESSOR.
>> I BELIEVE IN A FACT-BASED
REALITY.
AND FACT-BASED POLITICS.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN JUST MAKING
STUFF UP.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT EVEN THOUGH
MEDICAL DELL THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT ON THE
BALLOT IN ANY RACES, THEY ARE